He's waiting for him to go to Saga. The
moment he goes to Saga, he stabs him 57
times. Bro,
this is the cowardly of the cowardly
acts
because Islam is raising funds to
establish a masjid and community center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support. This donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation,
you will in be reaping the reward. Click
the link and donate what you can. Asalam
alalaykum. Welcome to brothers and
sisters and dear friends. I hope you
guys are well inshallah. Today's video
is something that we're going to share
with you guys which you may have heard.
I'm assuming most of you guys have not
heard. It's of the tragic stabbing to
death of a brother called Abu Bakr. Have
you heard of this? I haven't. This is I
did not even know about it until one of
our team members from Salam brother sent
it to me. I did not even know and subhan
Allah I was like why did we not hear
about this? This is an AB and and the
story is so wild because and it's kind
of close to home in the sense of it
happened in France. But this this this
is like the project that we're pushing
is our salah project where we teach
people how to pray salah. This guy walks
in, his name is Olivia, the scumbag,
dirt bag. He walks in and says to he's
like a caretaker. This brother, some say
he's Somali, we don't know. Um and asks
him, says that, "Oh, I'm interested in
Islam. Can you teach me how to pray?"
Any brother would jump at that chance
and find it an honor to teach somebody.
Exactly. It's a because we talk about
this with our charity. Teaching someone
how to pray salah, doing them learning.
It's a
subhan Allah. And he goes, "Yeah, of
course, bro. Look at this, bro. Look
what kind of a coward."
Yeah. That's the epitome. That's the
peak of cowardice a person is. You have
you shown the video yet? Watch the video
and let's just come just quickly. Watch
the video.
My money.
So you can clearly see he's waiting for
him to go to Sagda. The moment he goes
to Sagda, he stabs him 57 times, bro. 57
times.
This is the cowardly of the cowardly
acts because he knows that brother would
have smashed his face. Yes. He waits for
him to go to Saga and starts to stab him
from the neck. So he's going so he
doesn't have any chance to retaliate.
Yeah. Subhan Allah. And he kills him.
Subhan Allah. And to be honest, he
thinks that for Muslims, like what
happens in Palestine and Gaza or
whatever, like this is an honorable way
to die, my friend. Like you think
brother in teaching somebody how to pray
in the hands of somebody who is
antagonistic towards the dean. This
brother is a martyr 100%. And guess
what? On your where he we know where you
die, you'll be resurrected. Yeah.
Imagine that when he lifts his head up
inshallah jah. Yes. Subhan Allah.
Imagine if you go from s the closest you
are to your lord to in front of your
lord wah what an honorable way to die
you coward do you really think you've
harmed Islam you further show and now
the video I don't want to focus on this
which this is the main focus it is
subhanah where is tate I'm and look some
people might come and think why are you
obsessed no let me tell you why I'm
obsessed you in three separate occasions
attacks that took place by an ex-Muslim
by non-Muslims yes you did what blame
automatically said the perpetrator was a
Muslim. Three instances. So much so Sneo
even called you out. Yes. Three
instances. One when he was going to the
PBD uh podcast with that flipping
Islamophobe, what's his name? Flipping
pet Patrick pet. He's a pet. He's a
little Chihuahua. Yeah. Okay. That pet.
You go onto his show and automatically
come and say another Muslim was under
attack. Why are you lying, bro? Why are
you lying now? This attack happened. Why
you gone quiet, man? The perpetrator is
Look, the victim is a Muslim. No sound,
brother. I think this this is a pattern
that we're seeing. Although we're using
the name of Andrew Tate, he's the
archetype of the type of person that
only seems to put certain perpetrators
forward to forward a certain agenda. He
will always do and put forward certain
crimes and certain people that forwards
and pandas to his far right audience.
And you know, some say he went to
America. He pandered to the far right
hoping that they would give him a place
to stay and they rejected him. And then
now he's back in the mosque now and
trying to win back the Muslim audience
that he has physically physically harmed
through his lies, through his pandering.
I mean, one of the things that I say is
that there there are people that have
accepted Islam. This guy has at least a
few years have passed. I've never seen
the guy pray. I've never seen the guy,
you know, do some Islamic action even
though it's a vlog or something. And you
inadvertently, you don't do it just to
show people. It just happens because you
have been embodying certain teachings of
Islam or whatnot. I haven't seen any of
that. Frankly, it becomes second nature.
Certain stuff like bismillah before I
eat certain things. You get what I'm
trying to say? He he hasn't done it.
Subhan Allah. And now he's gone quiet.
Why didn't he talk about this, bro? Why
do he talk about this? And this is
disgusting. Look at this uh articles New
York Times. A killer, not a terrorist, a
killer. The Guardian. French Muslim
decry religious hatred at mosque. French
mosque stabbing. Uh French mosque
murder. Suspecting France mosque attack.
Yes. Why is the word terrorism not used
here, bro? If a Muslim went to a
synagogue, if a Muslim went to a church,
if a Muslim went to a Hindu temple and
did the done this, there will be out.
Let me tell you something. Outcry on a
different level. on their death. You
would hear about this for the next 57
times someone got stabbed and while they
were praying and while they were not a
threat at all going and faking that
you're a Muslim like how on earth is
this not on flipping everywhere on
headlines and the thing with that whole
andate thing is that you see a lot of
these people it's the same with the
Zionist thing it's the same with the
Kashmir thing it's the same with all of
these things that you only put forward a
certain crime if it's done by a certain
audience that puts forward your agenda
of dividing by political or religious
means. That's that's the bottom line.
Exactly. And the thing is, thank God the
non-Muslim community at large, they
don't buy this anymore. They do not buy
it anymore. Alhamdulillah, they've seen
the reality of Zionism, these people who
control the media, these Zionists, these
Zionists, they control the media,
Hollywood, you name it. Yes. They
control these Zionists. Yeah. And they
pull the strings. So people have woken
up. JF Kennedy's death. Call it a
conspiracy theory. No problem. And I
don't care. Guess what? They see the
pattern. They go, "Hold on a second,
man. All this time we've been lied to.
And these guys are the devils behind all
of this." So much so, I've seen Orthodox
Jews in Israel, bro, condemning these.
They're saying they're under our name.
They're doing it. Yes. They're doing
they're using our name. We're ashamed
because real Jews do not. We are exiled.
They accept. They They follow. At least
you give up to them, bro. We've got Jews
in Stampedil. Rabbi Beth that we know
who came to protest etc. They do not fit
in the same category. And the Jew we the
Jewish man we interviewed remember two
weeks ago he was talking about his
family abandoned him and boycotted him
because he's saying that because he said
ceasefire. So you can see the clear Jews
compared to these Zionist dirt bags you
know. Subhan Allah. So to me one thing
that I'm going to do is inshallah
because this is close to me in the sense
where we have a charity where we teach
people how to pray salah. I was thinking
imagine somebody comes to me and says
teach me how to pray and I trust him and
I'm in and the guy starts stabbing me.
Just imagine guys. So to me I'm going to
do a because it's close to me.
Alhamdulillah. Subhan Allah for our
charity a guided prayer inshallah. I'm
going to do that inshallah guys and do a
for all the Muslims but specifically
this brother inshallah that it's a me
because you know why he wanted to teach
that man how to pray salah and then he
was he was a scumbag. I'm going to
inshallah make sure that myself and
brother and sister if you want to do it
when you donate just say inshallah also
for brother Abu Bakr inshallah and may
it be a means that his legacies that
inspired us through our charity
inshallah you know what wall I'm going
to make sure that this becomes a for him
for him in what I'm going to try to
incorporate it some way into us that
we're going to remember this brother
because subhan allah we are opening
salah hubs bro even we haven't gone
France yet subhan allah wai it would be
an honor to go and if we open the salah
hub And remember, imagine going to his
masid and open a salah hub there where
he would have been one of the
instructors that want to teach people
how to pray salah. Subhan Allah. So may
may Allah have mercy on him in brothers
and sisters. And if you want to donate,
do for whatever under his name. It can
be for Palestine, it can be for our
charity, the salamat whatever inshallah
go and do it inshallah in his name and
for your loved ones as well who's passed
away. Inshallah Allah is the most
merciful. He would reward you for all of
them inshallah. And for Andrew Tate and
his lights where they are quiet in this
matter tells you everything. You can go
to the mosque as much as you like, bro.
But let me tell you something. Your
dealings with a Muslim speaks volumes.
That's all I have to say in any last
words. Well, you might go to the mosque
and you know, pictures are taken over
there, but you're safe in that mosque.
Yeah. Yeah. This brother was also in a
mosque and he was killed in that mosque.
Yes. Now, I would have expected somebody
that's in a mosque, knows what the
purpose of a mosque is, is in there
himself, would understand, and would
resonate with somebody who has been
killed and murdered in a mosque. But
let's
see and maybe maybe we've done too much.
We've done too much. It's run out is run
out. Let's see if he even mentions this.
Till next
time. Please keep the brother of
Abakran's family in your duas.